hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the Tata steel India
rapid Edition this is the one that you
guys requested a lot even though uh mvl
already won the tournament with a full
round to despair now this is the game
you guys wanted me to show it as a game
from round two pental Health Krishna
versus Google cash let's dive straight
into it and uh very much I'm interested
uh how did you how did you do with the
thumbnail challenge let me know in the
comment section uh let's check it out so
Hari Krishna has the white pieces and he
opens with D4 we have Knight F6 Knight
to F3 we have Pawn to D5 and Ponte E3 we
have Pawn to C6 uh so now with E3 uh
Hari Krishna went for the call system
and now usually Bishop to D3 is played
here this is the most common move and
sometimes you will play uh C for some
other music okay maybe not beat the D2
not very often you will see but here we
have Ponte H3 there are like five games
in the database with this uh setup and
uh Matthias blue blue bomb is pretty
much the only Grandmaster who tried it
against other Grand Masters although he
lost all the games he lost one Maxima
Sherlock and he lost one term Samuel
shankland but okay that's definitely an
attempt with H3 and now Bishop to F5 by
gukash and now they're okay Bishop the
D3 is the move that was played in those
games but Knight stage four is what Hari
Krishna goes for here and it is now as
of move 5 already that we have a
completely new game so Bishop goes back
to D7 and now Bishop to D3 so what uh
Hari Krishna got out of this is that he
doesn't have to trade off his light
Square bishop and his light Square
Bishop is a bit better than Google slide
Square bishop and D7 so Pawn to C5
gookish continues striking against a
hare krishna's Center uh C3 and now
Knight the C6 with Knight back to F3
Queen to C7 and not Knight B to D2 with
Ponte E5 striking in the center as white
always should and now Pawn to E4 and
when you see something like this this is
a extremely extremely difficult to
calculate especially for a rapid game so
chances are when you see a structure
like this players will just trade
everything off especially if this Pawn
comes to C4 then they will just trade
off everything no one is wasting their
time calculating this so see captures on
D4 see captors first Knight to B4 okay
you can attack the bishop before you uh
trade off the the rest of the pawns as
the bishop is not a defended you have to
react to that Bishop to B1 and now D
captures an E4 we have Knight characters
on E5 and now Rook the C8 and here comes
Knight captures on D7 already with a
very interesting idea that what happens
if Queen captures in C1 well it's just
not very good because if Queen
characters and C1 now first Knight
captures an F6 with check and if G
captures you will play Bishop captures
on e4 Now The Rook attacks the queen as
well so you have to trade captures
captures and okay you get this position
where white is up a pawn with a better
Pawn structure and okay you can grab the
pawn back but after Castle's white will
still always be better
uh so after night captures on D7 uh
gookish got a very different idea he
played King captures on D7 and now comes
Knight captures on e4 uh so what was the
Google's idea now Queen captures and C1
and now it's very much different we have
Knight the C5 with check now you cannot
uh just capture because if Bishop
captures then you lose the queen so you
have to capture with the Rook so what
was the idea behind Knight to C5 well
Bishop the F5 with check now opens up a
discovery towards the black queen so
Rook captures on F5 and now Rook
captures on C1 and now uh once all is
said and done you can see that Lucas
gave up his Queen but he also got three
pieces for the queen he has two knights
and the bishop for the queen which is
usually more than enough but here his
King is still in the center of the board
without any pawns to defend the uh the
king so is this worth it uh well let's
see how the game continues with Bishop
to D6 uh uh finishing development and
now uh castles of course you want to
play Queen B3 attack the Knight put
pressure on the B7 Pawn but you don't
want to allow Rook to E8 while your king
is still on E1 so that's why castles and
now Rook all the way to B8 we have Rook
to E1 and now Knight to C6 uh we have
rooked the C3 going for a nice Rook lift
and now Rook to D5 a book is just puts
pressure on this D for pawn and he is
ready to capture it we have rooked the
F3 uh Hari Krishna has to find any sort
of counter play and while you could
capture right away a first Rook to d8
and now he wants to bring his King over
to the queen side for extra safety for
example if Queen to B3 then you're just
gonna play King to C8 Defender B7 pawn
move the bishop and then you start
capturing and D4 and you will have a
great game
but after Rook 38 uh pental Hari Krishna
did not find any any any good
continuations and he decided to
sacrifice a little bit of material here
he played Rook captures on F6 G
characters and now Queen to F3 attacking
The Rook ended the pawn on F6 here so
King to C7 now of course The Rook cannot
be captured if you capture The Rook then
Bishop page to check will win back the
White Queen so after King to C7 we have
Queen captures an F6 and now Rook to D7
we have Pawn to G3 now so you don't run
into any sort of weird checks uh Knight
captures on D4 there was no way of
preventing this and King the G2 we have
knighted the C6 uh gookish wants to
solidify and now Rook to E2 so was the
exchange sacrifice all that worth it uh
very very hard to say but it doesn't
look like it uh yeah I mean if anything
uh the black king will be perfectly
defended you you gave um the semi-open G
file to be used for attack now a lot to
be done about this so Bishop to E5
attacking the queen we have Queen to H6
and now Pawn to F5 not even allowing the
H7 Pawn to be captured uh Rook the C2
and now Pawn to F4 now trying to open up
the position now of course if G captures
then you get the G file to attack the
white king So G4 by uh Hari Krishna and
King to B8 now we have Pawn to F3 now
comes Pawn to A6 and now this basically
becomes a game of how gookish will
convert this into a full point with Pawn
to H4 uh uh Hare Krishna is still hoping
to create a pass Pawn on the king side
there King to A7 uh we have Pawn to G5
Knight to B for going after the A2 Pawn
uh you could play A3 uh but not right
now as your rook and C2 is hanging so
Rook D2 and now Knight captures on A2
with Queen to E6 and now Bishop to C7
now the bishop will come to B6 not just
to control this diagonal but also to
prevent any and all checks that um the
White Queen uh could give to the black
king So Queen to F6 we have Knight to B4
uh and King to H3 we ignite the C6 now
comes Pawn to B4 uh but of course
um nothing to be done about that Knight
D5 we have Queen captures and F4 you
don't have to capture but you don't have
a better move uh here uh Hari Krishna is
basically without moves so he plays
Queen characters on F4 and now just
Knight the G6 attacks the queen we have
Queen E3 check and now Bishop to B6
blocks check Queen to C1 and now Rook to
D1 trying to get behind the white king
with Queen to C2 and Rook the H1 with
check with Rook to H2 and now Rook the
G1 cutting off the white king there in
the corner and the thread here of course
uh well there are many but Rook to D for
followed by Rook captures and H4
Checkmate is just one of them so you
have to stop and Rook the D2 is played
uh and now Knights the F4 with check
also a nice idea is just Rook the F7
followed by Rook to F4 and Rook to H for
checkmate it doesn't seem like there's
all that much you can do about this
about the bookish does I want to risk
anything you know
you know I'll try some unnecessary
calculation when there's a very very
simple Knight to F4 check King to H2 and
The Rook captures and D2 check Queen
character Sunday 2 and Rook to G2 check
uh eliminates the White Queen and Rook
of the board and of course now you know
your position is completely winning uh
requires zero calculation something
maybe maybe a couple Blanca would do so
Queen captures Knight captures King
captures and now Bishop to E3
uh this is a basically the final move of
the of the line you had to calculate
because without this move it's still
tricky you are probably winning but you
have to be very sure about it because if
white can get those pawns up the board
uh it's gonna be uh it's still a race so
you have to guard the df4 square uh
either via Bishop to C7 or Bishop to E3
uh gookish win for Bishop to E3 and now
King to G3 Pawn to B6 repairing Ponte A5
to create a pass pawn pawn to F4 and now
Pawn to A5 captures captures and he was
in this position and move 52 uh that uh
Hari Krishna pentala resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh for those of you in the previous
video I ended the game a bit too quickly
and some of you said that uh
uh well okay maybe I should have pointed
out how exactly black wins this uh so
okay I'm gonna show you now some of you
maybe know how to win this some of you
might be interested but okay white will
start pushing F5 of course white will
also try to create a pass Pawn here more
than one uh A4 You're Gonna Play F6 and
after A3 F7 of course now we're gonna
block the queening of the pawn with
Bishop to C5 so here comes H5 but after
A2 into G6 you you can capture you don't
have to capture doesn't really matter uh
you will play A1 Queen and that's it the
queen covers G7 the bishop covers f8
there's no way to advance the pawns and
you're just gonna play something like
this gobble up the pawns and then talk
about that a gobble up the fonts and
then uh checkmated the white king so
that's basically how you do it uh so
yeah uh very nicely done by gookash uh
if you have any other games that you
would like to see from this event do use
hashtag suggestion and I will very very
gladly uh go over them especially by mvl
who who won the tournament uh it's like
you guys never you know suggest any
games by Amy BL uh so uh yeah once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank obvious mimic.com Gerard
Prince and Bonbon uh Saul and baby boo
uh girls niches festival.org.gg and
Amanda Oliver the most beautiful girl in
the world for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of everything
else that's happening in the Chess World
and of course uh checking up on your
suggestions uh so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day
[Music]